one thing we like to do here is help the
audience understand changes to the rules
changes to the procedures things to be
on the lookout for when a new NFL season
begins and who better to talk to about
that than the NFL's senior VP of
officiating our River on back on the
program al great to talk to you how's
everything everything is good Mike had a
great offseason and great to be on your
show as usual well and it's great to
have a chance to talk to you as we get
closer and closer to the start of the
regular season the one topic that I want
to focus on the one thing that I get the
most questions about from my readers and
my audience is the adjustment to the
procedure for replay review the addition
of pass interference offensive and
defensive calls and non calls and I'm
just gonna open it up to you for a
general description of the most
important thing that you think the fans
need to know and to understand as that
first game of the regular season
approaches only one week from now well
Michael thank you and I and I think the
number one main thing is we have to
stress to all of our fans that it's not
a rule change per se the way that pass
interference both offensively and
defensively will be called or
administered on the field all it is is
that past interference has been added as
a reviewable aspect of the play such as
does the runner step on the line is a
runner down by contact is the
quarterback down with his knee being
touched before he throws it so again
pass interference on the field the way
it's called
will not change it's just another
reviewable aspect of the play the
difference here though is that those
other rules that you mentioned that are
subject to replay review objective
undeniable black and white it happened
or it didn't happen the ball was out
before the knee was down etc this is the
first foray into the subjective how does
the subjectivity of calling or not
calling pass interference factor into
what you will be doing when reviewing
the decisions that are made on the field
again Mike the premise of replay and as
we know replay and understand this is a
one-year rule so we're gonna look at
this we'll put down a whole bunch of
stats make a presentation to the
competition
in committee after the Super Bowl and
then they might tweak the rule they
might keep the rule the rule might go
away but again it's only a one-year rule
so the premise of replays we know it
Mike is that the ruling on the field is
the standard the ruling on the field is
correct whether we agree with the call
on the flag or not the flag that's not
where we're going we have to go in there
thinking this call is correct then based
on visual evidence afforded to us by the
network if it's clear and obvious
through visual evidence that the ruling
on the field is not correct then we will
change that ruling but again understand
it has to be clear and obvious and the
only thing that we are privy to is the
video evidence provided to us by our
network partners and beyond clear and
obvious which applies in every instance
of replay review what is the thing that
drives whether or not you will decide
based upon that review of the visual
evidence whether or not there is pass
interference if it wasn't called or if
there was not pass interference if it
was called well Mike and as you know
we're not really she ating the play what
we're looking at what was called on the
field and that's where we start so we're
not saying this is PII or it's not P I
we're looking at what's afforded to us
and then we go back to the basic
standards of what is pass interference
does this significantly hinder the
opponent's opportunity to make a play in
the ball and that's what we look at
based on what we see and what was called
now you've had 48 opportunities to
engage in replay review of pass
interference calls and Nan calls in 49
preseason games do you wish you'd have
more chances than that roughly one per
game and the preseason to to just be
certain that the kinks are worked out
and it's ready to go for the regular
season well Mike you're right we've had
48 situations where we rather had a
coach's challenge or replay both
stoppage or here from New York but
understand before we got into this all
the way back to the February we've
looked at thousands of plays and I'm
talking thousands of plays and we have
sat here and said what are we gonna do
with this and that's how we develop the
standard we went before the competition
committee and four days through a whole
bunch of different processes we started
in February here in New York the week
after the Super Bowl then we went to our
committee meetings in Indianapolis and
we sat with general managers coaches
players officials we explain the process
to them we got their opinion and then we
sat with the committee in March we
locked ourselves up in a room and we
went all over those plays and then again
we did it at the owners meeting in March
and each time we got input from all of
these different people a lot smarter
than I am and we came up with a standard
and the standard is clear and obvious
based on visual evidence so to answer
your original question it wasn't just
those 44 those 48 plates Michael it has
been thousands of plays that we've
looked at starting way back in February
but 48 instances of actually trying out
this new procedure in real time to get a
specific answer to a specific question
and let's fast forward to next weekend
we get into the Thursday night opener we
get into that full slate of Sunday games
what in your mind is the number one
concern you have in relation to whether
or not this is all going to go smoothly
and all the decisions are going to be
made properly really Mike we really
don't have any concerns other than we
have to stick to the process and the
process is the only way that we can make
a decision is based on the visual
evidence provided to us by network
partners there have been some situations
where coaches tape or local feeds have
come up and since we're not privy to
those shots the only way that we can
make a decision to be fair because again
we want to do the same thing in Miami at
1:00 o'clock as we do in Seattle at 1:00
o'clock and the only way that we can
standardize that it's too strict to rely
on what our network partners give us for
that particular game so we don't have a
lot of concerns the process except
itself has worked through preseason that
technology has worked that community
has worked so we feel we're in a good
place once the season kicks off next
sturgeon remember we have 16 games this
week also we have left
there have been no reversals so far of a
ruling on the field of pass interference
offensive or defensive roughly 20% of
the challenged rulings of no call on the
field have resulted in a reversal why do
you think there's that difference
between picking a flag up versus putting
a flag down
well again Michael I go back to the
clear and obvious visual evidence and
you're right we've had 48 reversals and
we've had I'm sorry we've had 48
challenges and 6 reversals and all of
those have been where we have put a flag
in the ground for lack of a better term
there has not there's been many
challenges but there has not been one
where we pick the flag up clear and
obvious visual evidence we have to make
sure there's no contact we have to make
sure that we have every single view as
far as the defender and the receiver
every single angle in a lot of these
situations we don't so we cannot assume
that something that not happen we cannot
assume that the official did not see
something and if we don't have every
single angle where we can make that
clear and obvious decision we won't do
it
now do we go in there same wall the flag
is on the ground we're gonna treat this
differently than when the flag is down
on the ground no we don't everything is
in a vacuum
that's preaching every single decision
and we treat them separately on their
own merits one key factor in all of this
al will be when the replay official
decides to initiate or not initiate a
review in those circumstances where the
on-site replay official has that
jurisdiction one thing I want to make
sure everybody understands because I had
some confusion in this regard
when specifically will it be that
threshold job of the replay official to
either activate replay review and send
it to you or let the game continue what
remember Mike just like in any other
situation for replay outside of two
minutes it must be a coach's challenge
and inside of 2 minutes on either half
then the replay official in the
takes over the standard again if it
doesn't stick out with the naked eye at
the place going on or the initial line
feed if that does not stick out to the
clear and obvious visual evidence to the
replay official he or she will not stop
the game now you have to stop for a
minute instead yourself well if they're
going fast if it's a hurry-up offense if
the clock is running you're basically
gonna get Mike the line feed and maybe
if you're lucky one replay in most
situations you're not however if it's an
incomplete pass or if the clock stops
because of a foul or the player the
runner goes out of bounds now we're
gonna have more time and I would think
the networks will give us more shots but
I know what you're talking about you're
talking about that hurry-up offense
where we're going down the field no
timeouts were under two minutes again if
it doesn't stick out with the naked eye
the initial line feed or any other quick
replay the official gets we're gonna
play football is the standard higher for
the replay official to stop the game for
potential pass interference replay
reviews than it is for other types of
automatic reviews initiated by the
replay official Mike all I would say is
that maybe it is we have more shots
available to us in other situations I
wouldn't say a higher standard the
standard is still the same clear and
obvious visual evidence but remember
when we're talking about pass
interference we're looking at so many
angles Mike we're looking at so many
situations where is their contact how
much contact did the context of
difficulty hinder your opponent so I
think there's a little bit more that
goes into it as far as what we need to
see in order to make a decision and just
so I'm clear on this the replay official
has that exclusive jurisdiction to
initiate the process in the final two
minutes of either half only touchdowns
turnovers those automatically go to you
for confirmation what happens in
overtime who's responsible then that
goes back to the replay official two
minutes instead of either half and
overtime it's ours and turnovers and
scores it's ours also and by the way
this year also might be a tease it's
ours so so for inside of two minutes and
overtime its replay official that has to
initiate everything else goes straight
to you well when we talk about straight
to me outside of two minutes it's a
coaches challenges a coaches challenge
and it comes to me but even when the
replay official stops it might it still
comes back to us your New York well oh
no I understand that that you make the
final decision I'm just trying to figure
out when the replay official is
essentially going to be the gatekeeper
that you may see the play and think oh
that looks like it should be overturned
but unless the replay official presses
the button you don't get the chance to
do that that's the one thing I want to
be clear on when will you be relying
upon the replay official to send it to
you before you even get the chance to do
it inside of two minutes it can be the
replay official or ourselves here in New
York so you can intervene even if the
replay official doesn't press the button
inside of two minutes yet okay all right
I got it now there was some talk about
maybe a different procedure different
standard for Hail Marys how is that
going to play out in this new replay
review environment for pass interference
so as you know Mike the Hail Mary
there's a lot of things that could
happen that's allowed that everyone
knows when there's a Hail Mary for
example there's some contact allowed
that generally will not be allowed when
it's just one receiver one defensive
back on a quote-unquote normal pass play
situations so everyone understands what
the philosophies and that is and the
committee and again we got input from
the coaches general managers president
players legends officials when we came
when we came back to the final way of
how we're gonna write this rule we
simply put in there that if that play
does go to replay either via a coaches
challenge or it stopped inside of two
minutes it will be officiated in replay
or it will be reviewed and replay I'm
sorry it will be reviewed and replay
under the same philosophies that it's
being allowed to be basically played on
the field so in other words we will not
apply a different standard when
reviewing that play and replay as
opposed to how it's officiated and as to
what is allowable on the field the same
way we're allowing the players to do
certain things when there's a Hail Mary
involved
it'll be reviewed and replay the same
way and that's kind of a it correct me
if I'm wrong now
that notion that a certain amount of
contact that beyond a hail-mary setting
would would draw a foul it's okay in a
Hail Mary that that's kind of a loose
interpretation of the pass interference
rules I did what is ultimately the
standard because it's not in the rule
book per se but but but but how do you
explain to a fan what is allowable in a
hail-mary setting that wouldn't
otherwise be allowable if it wasn't a
Hail Mary let me answer this question
this way Mike we actually tried in
there's a lot of things that the
committee vetted for example we vetted
allowing the coaches given an extra
timeout inside of two minutes that way
they can have a challenge throughout the
play there's a lot of things that
committee vetted we even talked about
how do we define the Hail Mary is it
from the 30 Mike it's on fourth down is
that under two minutes because you can
be in a situation let's say at three
minutes and the team is behind by two
scores and they might try a Hail Mary
throw it up and hopefully something
happens and then maybe get that score
and then under two minutes fight to see
if they can get the other score so again
there were so many variables and we did
not want to limit the players per se so
what is the Hail Mary I guess and and
and this might not be the scientific
answer that we're all looking for but I
think overall everyone understands when
we see it what a Hail Mary is and again
how do we define it outside the 30 1
minute and 28 seconds 35 yard line two
defensive players four offensive players
equal number of players how much pushing
how much shoving it's one of those
things Mike that when you know it you
see it and that's the hell Mary and when
something goes beyond the point of
what's allowable we will all agree on it
or maybe we won't
but I think for the most part Mike
everyone understands what's allowed
what's not allowed on the Hail Mary and
it's probably fortunate that we're not
putting this play into a box because
again it's something that when we see it
and when I say we I mean the football
community from fans the coaches the
players officials everyone involved and
Mike hopefully to on this one will all
agree that that's the hell Mary and
we'll understand what's allowable and
what's not hey one last
question and I know that's dangerous for
me to say because it seems like every
time I say that I ask more than one last
question but as it relates to defensive
pass interference there's been some
discussion from time to time about
possibly limiting the penalty to 15
yards not the spot foul that could be 40
50 60 yards or more do you believe al
that if this current procedure that's
being used for this year only if it's
made permanent do you think the next
logical step is to cap defensive pass
interference at 15 yards well Mike being
that I like you so much I'm not gonna
hold you to this last question because
that never happens with you now I'm
gonna answer your question okay
so Mike for the last probably five or
six years that I've been involved with
the committee that question has come up
do we go to 15 yards do we limit it
there
there's always been some heavy
conversation we've actually had
proposals from the club's let's limit it
to 15 yards we've looked at stats as to
how it affects the game and yes that
could be a 40 or 50 yard penalty it is a
steep penalty and of course Mike
sometimes were incorrect when we
appreciate those I don't think it's
gonna have a direct bearing Mike with
this rule I really don't
but again the stats might might prove me
wrong but again I think it's one of the
things regardless as to what happens
with this p.i rule going forward that
the committee will look at again I know
they've looked at it seriously every
year for the past five six probably
before I got involved with the
competition committee it's always a
topic for discussion we have the
n-c-double-a stats that we look at but
right now the committee feels that we're
in a good spot where we are al I'm gonna
honor my word that was my last question
I appreciate your time and I wish you
all the best I know that this is not an
easy assignment I know it's going to be
challenging and difficult in real-time
you're gonna have a lot of plates
spinning especially during that one
o'clock Eastern time window and it's
it's we wish you all the best because I
know I know you're gonna be feeling it
and we hope that it all works out well
and you get the camera angles you need
so you can make good decisions and Mike
I know that you're available if I need
help in that one o'clock window right
hey hey I'll be there
take that offer cuz I'll be there
mic always a pleasure thank you man
thanks I'll take care pal
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports